rendre dans un état d'âme encore une
fois je vais pas c'est pas pour faire de
la langue de bois mais c'est un principe
fondamental auquel moi je crois et je
pense que ça tient la république donc
c'est extrêmement important
moi je vais pas commenter un fait divers
c'est un fait divers les images elles
sont choquants tellement choquée moi
aussi mais je connais pas l'ensemble du
dossier l'ensemble de la chaîne de
commandement donc je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé pas plus que vous et donc je
fais confiance moi en la justice de mon
pays il ya eu hier une saisine par le
parquet pour accomplir sa mission est
donnée rendre des comptes
l'ensemble des citoyens est-ce qu'on
n'est pas au delà du simple fait divers
vous parler de faits divers savage au
delà quand même je crois pas c'est
encore une fois vous ne pouvez jamais
juger un dossier sur des éléments
factuels sur des éléments de cette
dimension vous avez un extrait vidéo qui
est choquant personne ne dira à
l'inversé inacceptable la loi est très
claire
vous n'avez pas pourrez commenter très
bien c'est ne voulait pas commander
toute la globalité des faits puisqu'on
ne connaît pas et que les socialistes
j'ai la même ligne je vais vous dire je
suis de la déclaration de bruno roger pg
la mélanine sur l'ortf aaron de l'elysée
j'ai la même ligne sur l'ensemble des
représentants politiques vous savez ces
jeux c'est vraiment hors coloration
politique j'ai la même ligne pour eric
woerth
j'ai la même ligne pour marine le pen
n'a rien à voir ne mélangeons pas tout à
fait si quelqu'un est pris la main dans
le pot de confiture sur les si je fais
le tour du cateau maintenant janvier aux
mains avec vous devant témoins avec des
caméras
évidemment qu'il n'y aura pas besoin d'
enquête pour voir où elle tort et que
j'ai et que mon comportement
irrépréhensible en tant que député
représentant de la nation mais c'est
pour ça que je veux dire c'est à dire
que j'ai si oui c'est la réponse ne vous
satisfait pas mais c'est la mienne j'ai
11 ans d'expérience pardonnez-moi 11 ans
d'expérience d'auxiliaires de justice
je suis totalement d accord exclusif
alors hier justement le débat s'est
invité que ce soit à l'assemblée
nationale ou au sénat
on va tout de suite écouter edouard
philippe edouard philippe y étaient
interpellés lors des questions au
gouvernement dans l'hémicycle du sénat
et coûter le premier ministre la sphère
elle est désormais aux mains de la
justice
et c'est très bien ainsi
elle est désarmée elle est désormais aux
mains de la justice
et c'est très bien ainsi un certain
nombre un certain nombre de questions ne
manqueront pas d'être posée
je souhaite nous souhaitons tous que
cette enquête permette de déterminer les
faits précis les raisons claires
l'enchaînement des décisions qui ont été
prises sur ce sujet je vous remercie et
charles alpin oui très bien non plus on
vient d'entendre le premier ministre
s'est exprimé hier au sénat il n'y a pas
qu'au sénat on a parlé beaucoup de cette
affaire hier vous étiez à l'assemblée
nationale les débats ont été phagocyté
par cette affaire benalla alors que les
députés discutent et je vous écoute et
tout à l'heure vous disiez vous
discutiez de la possibilité en fait de
revaloriser le parlement dans ses
fonctions notamment de contrôle
d'évaluation alors même que tous les
bancs de l'opposition appelé justement
edouard philippe le premier ministe à
venir s'exprimer sur cette affaire il a
refusé ce que vous trouvez pas ça
paradoxal
ce que je trouve paradoxal c'est que les
oppositions ont invoqué la séparation
des pouvoirs
montesquieu l'esprit dès lors d'esprit
des lois de l'esprit des lois exactement
et on aurait voulu et on voudrait ce que
les oppositions demandé au fond que le
parlement français se transforme en
autorité judiciaire on est en confusion
totale des rôles de chacun et ça c'est
un danger et ça c'est garanti vous savez
pas quel texte
le texte qu'on est en train de réviser
la constitution donc c'est à dire que la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire qui a
été validée qui a été approuvé par
l'assemblée nationale pour vous ce n'est
pas une bonne chose
moi je pense que seule l'autorité
judiciaire peut faire justice etc
les procédures qui sont en cours on en
parlait tout à l'heure donc je laisse le
chemin la justice avait encore une fois
la justice est suffisamment complexe et
suffisamment essentiel pour le laisser
entre les mains de professionnels du
sujet
qui vont analyser décortiquer rendre
compte et prononcer des sanctions en cas
de chute une commission sera pas utile
selon vous c'est en gros une façon de
débloquer une obstruction d'une journée
par des oppositions
ça démontre aussi quand même la vacuité
des oppositions à pardonnez moi de vous
le dire mais quand on passe une après
midi jeux vous redonner le chiffre de
deux millions et demi par jour le coût
du parlement la démocratie n'a pas de
prix mais elle a un coût c'est deux
millions et demi par jour à faire ça
alors que chacun est persuadé en dehors
de l'hémicycle que c'est un fait divers
en réalité que tout le monde a bien
conscience qu'on est en train de
politiser un fait divers mais je crois
qu'on n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
et je crois surtout qu'on n'est pas à la
hauteur des ambitions qui sont les
nôtres et des attentes des français
dre les français je crois en tout cas ce
que je croise moins les bretons pas que
les bretons mais des français ils
attendent de nous concrètement encore
une fois du concret sur le chômage sur
l'école sur la formation sur la santé
etc et un peu d'exemplarité aussi belle
exemplarité justement c'est ce qu'ont
produit nous concrètement mais là vous
me dites produire de l'exemplarité mais
c'est le le texte la loi confiance c'est
ce qu'on est en train de faire nous
toutes les actions transparence et
d'exemple sur juste sur sur l'assemblée
nationale là je reprends ma casquette de
questeur quand on aligne sur le droit
commun le régime de retraite des députés
qu'on cela pique à nous mêmes au 1er
janvier dernier
ça c'est l'exemplarité